Rob Kardashian is getting his life in
check I feel like I'm in a really really
good place I just have to stick to the
plan the reality stars daughter dream is
turning 3 in November and it seems this
milestone is giving him a much-needed
kick in the butt a source tells ET that
the 32 year old Papa is relishing
fatherhood and is ready to take control
of his life and health for his
daughter's face on Monday Rob returned
to the gym tweeting this photo of his
view with the caption day one all good
according to our source having a
daughter has made him realize how much
more important it is for him to get back
into the gym and eating healthy this or
that that Rob is now in a very good
place and ready to take control of his
life again this is life-threatening at
this point you could only sustain this
level of being unhealthy for so long of
course the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians star has these challenges
with his health and weight over the
years it is a shock to me because a
1-point I'm super healthy and I'm 26
years old but now I'm at my worst and I
got serious health issues and numbers
that are just crazy freaking my whole
family out but in January a source told
ET he was on the right track and was
happier and getting healthier while
focusing on fatherhood no keys
meanwhile little dream has been spending
some time with her uncle Kanye West Rob
tweeted this cute snap of the two in a
cafe on Monday riding best picture ever
at Kim Kardashian and he even wished
himself a Happy Father's Day on Sunday
posting this sweet throwback photo of
him cuddling his daughter
[Music]